(indistinct chattering)
- Okay, so before we get started,
I want to touch base a little bit
about what is multi-channel marketing
and what does it, what
are some of the challenges
that are associated with
multi-channel marketing
and how agentic AI can help in solving
some of those challenges?
So, multi-channel marketing
is a customer centric
strat, marketing strategy
where you are providing
seamless integrated experiences
to your customers at the touchpoints
where they are interacting
with your particular brand, right?
And at the same time, you need to ensure
that there is consistent messaging
across all these channels
that they're interacting with your brand.
So, let's take a look at some
of the challenges that come with it.
You know, when it comes
to automating multi-channel marketing
and how agentic AI can help.
And I will cover what
does agentic AI mean,
you know, how we evolved into agentic AI
and all those details
in the upcoming slides.
So first, let's look at
the business problem.
So, the first challenge
with multi-channel marketing automation
is associated with the workflows
that you need to orchestrate.
You know, there are
different customer journeys,
there are multiple channels, there are,
you know, different
touchpoints for your customers.
And how do you ensure that,
you know, you have this overall workflow,
you know, deployed in a way
that it is flexible enough, right?
With traditional workflows,
they're kind of too rigid
and they're like, you know,
sticking to a particular script.
But whereas when it
comes to agentic AI based
or agentic AI enabled workflows,
you will have the flexibility
to have multiple agents,
you know, coordinating with
each other in real time.
And they can even have,
like, specialized agents
that are built for specific
marketing channels.
You can also have dynamic workflow.
Let's say your customer responses
and behavior is a little bit different
than what what is expected
the agentic AI based workflow
can adopt based on your customer behavior.
And you can also have
cross-channel context preservation
and you can deliver consistent messaging
across all these channels
that you're trying
to reach them on.
You know, whether it be
email, SMS, you know, online,
you know, web personalization,
social media and so on.
Then there is the challenge of,
you know, real-time personalization,
whatever that you're delivering,
the messaging that you're
delivering to your customers,
you know, personalizing
to those customers.
You have thousands of customers,
you know, across multiple
channels when you,
when it comes to that level of, you know,
that kind of a scale, agentic
AI can definitely help
in that situation.
With the traditional systems that,
you know, they usually lack the ability
to deal with those kind of things.
And, you know, the complexity
that comes with it.
So, with agentic AI based systems,
you can have intelligent
content generation.
So, depending on the
particular customer segment
and customer behavior and so on,
you can dynamically generate
what specific content makes sense
for that particular customer
and that particular channel.
You can also do real-time
decision making in terms
of, okay, the customer
is more interacting on,
through email, you know,
or they're more interacting
on social media platforms.
So, depending on the kind of
interactions that you're seeing
and observing for your customers,
you can switch between
different channels as necessary.
And you can also have brand guardrails,
baked into the AI agents themselves.
That way you have that brand
consistency and compliance,
you know, already built into the AI agents
and you don't have to worry about it.
So, the next challenge is with,
you know, with any typical enterprise,
you know, you see these data silos,
you know, data sitting
across your CRM systems,
your e-commerce systems, your
your data analytics systems
and so on and so forth.
And looking at it all this
data in a holistic way
and acting upon the data, the
customer data that you are,
that you have across all these systems
is pretty complicated in nature.
Where agentic AI can help is build
that unified data point of view.
You know, you can have
APIs and MCP Servers
that are exposing the data
from these individual systems
and agents can actually get all the data
from these different systems,
associated with a specific customer
and identify their behavior
and the patterns associated with them.
You can also have things
like data cleansing,
you know, there may be certain places
where you need to cleanse data
that is coming from your CRM
system or some other system,
or you may have to do some data mapping
between different systems.
All those things you can
automagically achieve
using agentic AI.
Then there is the Speed to Market
and Campaign Agility aspect of it, right?
So, traditional, if you look
at traditional marketing campaigns,
they take a lot of time to set up, right?
You know, whether it be
the content generation,
whether it be, you know,
think of how to customize it,
what are the target or segmented audience
that we are targeting at that
particular point in time.
All those things, they actually take a lot
of weeks of effort, whereas
by, and by that time
you would basically miss
market opportunities, right?
You know, it's gone, right?
With agentic AI,
you can have natural language
based campaign definition.
So, you can say, I'm
trying to target audience
that are like under 25 years
of age who use Instagram
a lot or, you know, some other
social media platform a lot
and living in California,
living in so and so city.
And you just provide the definition
of the campaign in a natural language way
and the agents will be
able to understand that,
identify the right audience,
identify the right content
that needs to be generated and so on.
You can also have instant
campaign optimization.
So, let's say your performance,
the campaign performance data
is coming through, like, it is streaming
and you want these AI agents
to look at what is going on
and if you need to optimize
then and there, you can do that.
You can have that real-time
campaign optimization in place.
And then there is the, one of the biggest
of the challenges is the Attribution
and ROI Measurement Across
all these Touchpoints.
So, it's not single touchpoints.
So, you have these emails
that are going out,
those SMS messages that are going out,
they're interacting with
your brand at a store.
So, there are so many
different touchpoints
at which your customers are
interacting with your brand.
So, with agentic AI, you can have
that intelligent attribution modeling
that accounts for all these different,
you know, touchpoints and all
the complex customer journeys
across all these touchpoints.
You can also have
real-time ROI optimization.
So, you can actually see where
or which particular channel
is performing better
versus other channels.
So, let's say your marketing
campaign is targeted for like,
okay, I need to send 10,000 emails
and I need to target the same thing,
the same campaign on like
social media platform,
but you are seeing more responsiveness
on the social media
platform versus the email.
So, you can also quickly
switch between channels
so that it's much more optimized
and you are spending the right
money on the right things.
You can also perform like
predictive analytics.
So, even before you are executing
your marketing campaigns,
you can start by, you know, measuring what
or estimating what would be
this campaign performance
if I am executing across these channels,
if I am targeting these
particular audiences,
how exactly this is going to,
this campaign is going to perform, right?
So, all those things you can bake in
into your agentic AI workflows.
All right, so I did promise
you that I will cover
what does agentic AI mean
in the first place, right?
So, and how did we evolve
into agentic AI today?
So, on the left hand side...
Yes, on the right hand side for you,
you'll see the low agency systems, right?
You know, these are traditional systems
where they're completely rule-based
and they require a lot of human oversight.
And on the extreme left side, right side,
you see there are high agency systems
which don't need much of human oversight.
So, traditionally, companies
have usually started,
like, around using rule-based RPA
or Robotic Process Automation,
which are kind of rigid in nature.
They're task oriented.
So you say, this is exactly
the task I want to accomplish.
These are the set of rules
that are associated with this task
and they can only focus on that
and they require a lot of human oversight.
And then came the generative AI assistance
where they know what they
need to do for specific tasks.
You are not, humans are not
significantly involved in that,
but they still need some
level of human oversight.
You can just say, this is the task
that you're supposed to do
and they will do it for you.
They, you know, think of it
as some examples are, like, you can have
these customer service chat assistance,
which are, you know, powered
by AI behind the scenes
or your, you know, intelligent
document processing.
You know, you can just
read through the document.
It is supposed to just
go through the document,
understand what the document contains
and be done with it, right?
So, it understands what
tasks need to be done
and it'll do it by itself,
but you still have to define the workflow.
You still have to tell that
generative AI assistant
what exactly it is supposed to do.
And then came the
goal-driven agents, right?
They're kind of the next level,
and this is where
we started seeing real
business transformation, right?
We, these things understand
what is the business objective.
You're not defining
individual tasks anymore.
You're basically saying,
"This is my business objective,
now please go do this."
And these agents are able
to come up with the tasks,
intelligent tasks, that need
to be executed, the workflow,
the order, and so on so forth.
And execute those and
accomplish those objectives
that you're trying to achieve.
And then there is a fully
autonomous agentic systems.
These are kind of rare today,
we don't have a lot of them,
but this is where, this is
the highest level of agency
and this is the highest level of autonomy
that we are working towards.
And these systems, they can
make strategic decisions
on your behalf.
You know, they're not just,
you know, business objective oriented.
Now they're able to make
decisions on your behalf,
interact with other agents,
interact with other tools
and, you know, make,
let's say, make a payment
on your behalf or, you
know, those kind of things.
Okay, so what does an
AI agent mean, right?
So, you may have heard about,
you know, or been using
LLMs, large language models
or small language models, and so on.
Where they lack the
ability to solve problems.
You know, they're like, you say,
"Okay, can you write me a poem?"
They'll write a poem,
but they don't exactly know...
If you say this is my
objective, go do something,
they will not be able to do it.
You have to specify what needs to be done.
Whereas AI agents are autonomous
or semi-autonomous software systems
that are able to independently plan, act
on your behalf with
minimal human oversight.
And they're also able to
interact with the environment
that they're in, you know,
whether it be the APIs,
the data sources that you have,
you know, all those things
and able to take independent
decisions on their own.
So, it is relatively
easy to build an agent,
you know, for those who have
already built AI agents,
you already know how easy
it is to build AI agents.
But when it comes to
taking them to production,
you know, think of all things
that need to happen when it needs
to go into production, right?
Think of the thousands of invocations
that will, potentially, happen
for that particular agent.
Think of the thousands of interactions
that this agent will have with other agent
and other tools as necessary.
All these complexities that are in place,
and if you have to manage your
own infrastructure for this,
they're not going into production, right?
This is where most of the customers
are like building AI agents.
They're doing prototypes and
not taking them to production.
And that's where Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore services
come into picture.
So, AgentCore services let you
build, deploy, scale, secure
and observe your AI agents in production.
And you can use any agentic framework.
So, if you're familiar with LangGraph
or, you know, CrewAI, Strands,
all these different agentic frameworks,
you can use any framework
and you can also use any LLM, right?
You can use, you know,
the Bedrock based models,
whether it be the cloud models and so on.
You can use OpenAI models,
you can use Gemini models,
you can use anything that you want, right?
That's the flexibility that
AgentCore services provide you.
So, AgentCore is a set
of modular services,
which you can use all of them
or some of them as necessary
for your particular situation.
You don't have to use
every service out there,
you just pick and choose
the ones that make sense
for your particular
agentic AI application.
The first one out of the
services is AgentCore Runtime.
So, runtime allows, as the name suggests,
it allows you to run your
AI agents and MCP servers
and it is completely or
fully managed service.
You're not managing any
of the infrastructure.
You're only purely focused on
what your AI agent needs to do
and the code associated with it,
and you go deploy it in there
and it is secure in nature.
You, you know, it has
its own session isolation
and other capabilities.
Also there are data
protection capabilities
and all those things that come,
baked in into the runtime itself.
You can have real-time interactive agents
or you can have long running agents,
agents that may be running up
to eight hours of duration.
Then there is the
AgentCore Identity service,
which allows your AI
agents to securely interact
with their other services,
whether it be your enterprise APIs
or, you know, other
services, like, whether
it be interacting with
your Salesforce or Slack
or, you know, Google, you
know, all these GitHub,
all these things that
are external services
as well can be accessed securely
using AgentCore Identity.
It basically reduces,
you know, when you think
of authentication
authorization lifecycle, right?
You know your AI agent,
let's say it needs to go talk
to Salesforce.
First, the user has to authenticate,
then there needs to be some
level of token exchange
that is happening between
Salesforce and the user itself.
You know, you got the token,
but now that token has to
be passed to your AI agent
to go continue doing the work, right?
So, all those, storing those,
you know, tokens in a secure world,
making sure that only the agent
that is supposed to access the token
is able to access it, you
know, and reusing tokens
as necessary.
These tokens don't just expire, right?
You know, sometimes you
have longer duration tokens,
one hour, two hour,
whatever the job tokens that you generate.
So, depending on that, you know,
and you don't have to write
even a single piece of code.
All that you do is you'll reference couple
of decorator functions
of AgentCode Identity
and you will be able to,
all the boiler plate
code that is necessary
for authentication
authorization will go away.
So, that reduces the
amount of development time
that is required for you to
take your agent to production.
You're not writing any
piece of code over there,
you're just using inbuilt capabilities.
And the beauty of it is
it already integrates
with some of the, you
know, identity providers,
whether it be your Okta, your Cognito,
you know, think of Entra ID and so on.
Then there is the AgentCode Gateway,
which provides a secure
mechanism to integrate
with your existing, you know,
APIs and Lambda functions
or even external services and so on.
And what it does is it is acting
as a name suggests, it
is acting as a gateway
between all your APIs
and it can convert those APIs
into MCP compatible tools.
So, you don't have
to build your own MCP
servers in front of your APIs
and Lambda functions
and other AWS services.
You can just leverage
Bedrock AgentCode gateway
so that, you know, it just
helps you with that MCP exposure
and your agents are able to talk
to that MCP through that protocol.
It also allows for like, you know,
let's say you have thousands
of APIs across your enterprise
and most of them you're trying
to convert them into MCP
servers and tools basically.
When the tool collection keeps growing
and when your agent is trying to go find
what are all the tools that are available,
you know, it, the context window
for your agent keeps getting bloated up
and, you know, you don't wanna do that.
Where Gateway shines is it provides you
with a semantic search
kind of a capability
where the agent will say, "Hey,
I'm trying to send an email,
can you give me a tool
associated with it?"
And Gateway will pick and
choose the specific tools
that make sense for signing an email
and expose only those
tools with, to the agent
so that your agent context window
is not bloating up or go going overblown.
Then there is the AgentCore Memory.
So, in case if you want to have memory,
you know, associated with your AI agents
and you want to store
and retrieve information
across multiple sessions
of your or invocations
of your AI agents, you
can leverage memory.
It has both short term and
long term memory capabilities.
So, depending on what
information you want to store,
what type of AI agent you're building
and whether it requires
some level of data retention
for, you know, some level of chat history
or whatever your agent is doing,
if it requires memory,
the AgentCore Memory
will help you with that.
And then finally there is
a AgentCore Observability.
This is a fully managed
ability or service,
sorry, which will help you to take
that single pane of
glass of kind of a view
into what exactly your AI agent is doing.
What model it is calling,
how many tokens are used,
what are the inputs, what are the outputs,
what tools it is calling or
MCP service that it is calling.
So, you get that auditability
and observability,
right in the service itself
and some of the frameworks like Strands
and all these things, they already
have those things baked in
and all the logs, metrics, traces
are open telemetry compatible.
So, if you want to push those logs
into CloudWatch or Datadog
or Cloudsmith, Langfuse,
you know, all those different
tools you can do so.
With that said, I will like to hand it out
to Jiten, he'll cover the
architecture patterns.
- Thank you Sandeep for covering
the marketing automation challenges
and the what and whys of AgentCore.
Hi, I'm Jiten Dedhia.
I'm a Senior Solution
Architect specializing with AI,
ML and GenAI.
I cover the advertising
and marketing industry across the US.
Just with the show of hand,
I'd just like to know how many of you guys
are from advertising marketing industry?
Okay, just few of them.
So, good thing is whatever
I'm going to cover
or while it may have focus
on advertising marketing,
it is going to be
applicable across the board.
So, any of your use case,
financial services, life sciences,
everything is going to be applicable.
Same thing.
What I'm going to do is deep dive
on how to use AgentCore
or how to use agent, multi-agent system.
What are the patterns?
What are important things to consider
and will deep dive into
those aspects of it.
In particular, we'll start with like agent
to agent communication,
what are the options of
pros and cons for that?
Then we'll go into security aspect of it
and finally like multi-tenancy
and observability.
So, let's take a distributed
communication system, right?
Like, multi-agent system.
The communication is
like the nervous system
of the brain of it.
Here what we are have is
multiple agents are shown here.
These are marketing related agent,
but, as I said, like it
they could be any agent.
As Sandeep has referenced,
these agents could be
built using any framework.
So, one thing we are propagating
is that don't necessarily
restrict your team
to using one kind of framework.
You could use LangGraph.
Some teams could use LangGraph,
others could use Strands, right?
And it's perfectly cohesive system.
They can talk to each other very smoothly
within AgentCore Runtime.
So, that's not a restriction.
Now if you want to standardize
as an enterprise on one thing, it's fine,
but it doesn't have to be,
and that's something you
need to realize with this.
Here you see like an user, he's
going to typically interact
with an application, maybe
an existing application,
maybe a new application.
It could be chat or it could be a web app.
And then what the application
is going to do is,
that is the application
going to communicate with one
of the agents or multiple of these?
In many scenarios you will see
that there is an orchestrator agent.
So, the application hands
off to the orchestrator
and then the orchestrator is
going to decide who it needs
to talk to, when it should talk
to each one of these agents.
Now, let's see, how can it
talk to these agents, right?
So the, we have few options here.
You can see here there's Boto3
and then there is A-2-A, right?
So, let's say the application first calls
using a Boto3 API, it invokes
the orchestrator agent.
The orchestrator agent now has a choice.
It can use Boto3 APIs to
invoke the other agent.
It can use A-2-A communication.
When would you use which one?
Right?
As an enterprise you need to
standardize, not necessarily.
AWS Boto3 will give you
builtin retry logic.
Will give you error handling,
some of those native things
that you're used to, right?
It'll make your life simpler.
When would you use A-2-A then?
A-2-A is going to be an
open source protocol.
So if you want to
standardize on open source.
What if you have agents out,
living outside of AWS
that you need to call?
Maybe those cases are when
you would typically go
for an A-2-A kind of approach.
Now, imagine a world,
and this probably is true for many of you
who have been building agents for a while.
Before AgentCore came out,
before deploying it to AgentCore,
what you would typically
do is maybe you have
an ECS container, or EKS, or Kubernetes,
like, where you would've
written your LangGraph agent
and you would've deployed it there.
Now, these are, those agents
legacy agents as I call it.
They're still there and you
start building new agents
and you start deploying them in AgentCode.
They need to talk to the old agent as well
and that's where probably
you would use APIs
to make the call to those agent.
You'll write a tool
within one of your agents
or the orchestrator agent,
and that tool may call out as an API
to these other agents
which are sitting in ECS
or any other container.
Then we take the next case.
So, here is where it gets
a little bit more complex use case,
but this is a real life
enterprise situation.
There are multiple
teams developing agents.
There are reasons where you will need
to use multiple AWS account.
So, maybe some of your agents
are deployed in this account,
others in this and another
in a third account, right?
When are those use cases?
One, as I said, is
there are multiple teams
who are developing them.
So, for ownership purposes,
for cost allocation
purposes, you need that.
But then there are use cases
where, let's say, you have a database
which is sitting in, on account A
and your agent needs
to interact with that.
So, in that case you
may want to, your agent,
to be sitting in that account and talking
to your database there,
but then the other agents will
need to talk to that agent
and that's where you will need
to do communication between them.
Another use case is
shared services, right?
Maybe there are some shared
services, type agents,
that are written as a common
framework for your enterprise.
Those agent could be living in
a different account as well.
So, again, you'll need to
communicate across AWS account
in those cases.
And, but either ways
the same thing applies
whether it's within the same
account or cross account,
you still can use the Boto3 APIs
or you can still use
the A-2-A communication.
So, you don't have to worry about that
and feel free to deploy
it wherever you need to,
based on your use case.
The next is an MCP server.
So, typically, agents will require tools.
Tools are going to be
written as an MCP server.
Now, how do you communicate
to an MCP server using
the MCP protocol, right?
So, that is available,
out of the box, as well.
With AgentCode.
So, those were the patterns to
communicate with each other.
Now what about security?
I'll say, like, if you
ask your security team,
the first thing they'll say is,
"How do you control the
access to the agents?"
So, that's the thing, right?
The authentication, the authorization,
the fine grain control, all that is needed
for multi-agent orchestration.
So, what are the options
thus that we have here?
So, basically we have two
choice, again, here to make
between the two IAM authentication
and OAuth.
OAuth, you need an OAuth provider
which can do the OAuth
token generation for you.
IAM is the native AWS
authentication that you can use.
Both of those options are available
and, again, you can mix and match.
You don't have to choose
one over the other.
You can decide to,
some agents can use IAM authentication
while others can use OAuth.
For an MCP server, again, here
the standard MCP uses OAuth,
but we have modified that within AgentCore
to use IAM as well.
So, if you deploy an MCP server
within AWS AI AgentCore Runtime,
then you can use just IAM
authentication as well.
So, then you can do
native IAM authentication
across the board, if that's
your preferred choice.
With OAuth you, typically,
require an OAuth provider,
either Cognito, Okta or
any other OAuth provider.
If you are not familiar with it.
What the process is,
is basically your OAuth provider
is set up for a certain agent.
It can generate token.
That token comes when you call the agent.
You'll pass that token along with it.
Now, here's the beauty of it.
What AgentCore does is it's going
to intercept every single request.
It was going to inspect it.
It's going to see whether the
OAuth token is present or not.
Once the OAuth token is present,
it's going to go to the OAuth
provider, validated the token,
and only then the first line
of your code gets caught.
So, that's where the security comes in.
That's relieving you of the security job.
We are guarantee you that
we will be intercepting
the code, will be taking
care of the authentication
and only valid requests
are coming through.
So, that is very important
thing to note here.
There are two cases of OAuth tokens.
One is a user generated OAuth
and another is machine
to machine OAuth tokens.
So, there are two types of tokens
that you could use potentially.
When do you use which one?
So, as we see, first the
user is calling the app,
the app is calling this,
though that, you will use
the user generated token.
So, the user's identity is getting passed,
the token generated by
the user will get passed,
you'll use that.
But then maybe between
the two agent to agents
or between an agent to an MCP,
those are machine to machine things.
You may want to just use a
machine to machine token.
Again, AgentCore Identity
supports both of those options
and you can use any of them.
Another thing, sometimes you need
is the user's identity needs
to get propagated further
to the MCP server, right?
You have an MCP server, which is a tool,
let's say it's accessing database.
You want to limit the access
based on who the user was
and in that case you will you,
pass on the user's identity
onto the MCP server
and make that decision.
If that is not the case, then use
the machine-to-machine token,
makes your life simpler.
Sometimes you do need fine
grained even further down.
So for example, you may have an agent
that is doing multiple task
and then you need to
have fine grained control
and that is something you may need
to implement using code
within your AgentCode.
And how do you do that?
So, what we do is the
identity that is passed on,
we allow you with easy methods to extract
that identity token from the
request, from the context.
So, you can get the user's identity.
Now you can inspect it
and you can see, oh, is this user allowed
to do operation A and B?
Then keep doing both the operation.
If it's only allowed to do operation A
then just allow him to do operation A,
and that is something that
you built in with your code.
Next, we decide, like, how
do we decide between IAM
or OAuth, when to use which?
Again, the decision is simple.
If you want to stay in AWS ecosystem,
if you're using just AWS across the board,
you can keep using IAM and
makes your life simpler.
Also, when you're
starting up a new project,
it's much simpler to just use IAM
unless you have already used
OAuth in other places, right?
So, then it becomes simpler, setup wise,
getting up and running very quickly.
Now, on the other hand, OAuth,
if you're already familiar
with OAuth, if your organization
has an OAuth provider already set up
or if you want to call
across cloud, right?
Like if you want to do have
the cross-cloud compliant,
if you want to use open
source standards only,
then OAuth is the way to go.
Little bit more setup at the beginning,
but then it's standard it,
you can use it across the board as well.
The next we go is when we
set about multi account.
If you are using IAM, then you may need
to use cross account roles.
That's the only difference.
But other than that, it
still says, stays the same.
Finally, we'll talk about the gateway.
So, if you remember Sandeep
spoke about AgentCore Gateway.
This is where if you have enterprise APIs,
so a lot of enterprise APIs,
what you don't realize is
you start writing MCP servers
and wrapping around it.
You don't need to do that.
You can just use AgentCore
Gateway to do it.
But as soon as you introduce this,
how do we do security around it?
How do we do authentication
and authorization for
AgentCore Gateway, right?
So, AgentCore Gateway supports
OAuth as your mechanism.
It exposes everything as
an MCP server by itself.
So, it will allow you to do OAuth.
So, now an agent needs to call an API
that is living in your enterprise.
What you do is introduce the gateway.
You supply an M2M token to
the gateway or M2M token
and that token, AgentCore
Gateway will verify, validate it
and only if it's valid, it'll
pass it on or call your APIs.
It's not going to call
your APIs otherwise.
So, that's, again, the
built-in security that you get.
Then let's say your token is valid.
Now, how do you call your APIs?
So, your enterprise may
have secure API keys
for calling the APIs.
They may be already using
OAuth to authenticate
with your APIs or there could be nothing.
Maybe it's unprotected APIs.
So, all of those options can be supported
by AgentCore Gateway.
So, gateway can be configured to say,
okay, this API is protected
by an API key while this other
API is protected by OAuth
and you can mix and match again.
The key is don't change
necessarily your API code
to do anything.
Just configure the AgentCode Gateway
to use your existing API,
makes your life simpler
across the board and then
expose it as an MCP server.
So, we saw how to communicate
between multiple agent,
then we saw how to secure them.
Now, let's get into multi-tenancy.
So, this is a real
requirement in many use cases.
The multi-tenancy patterns
here are very similar
if you were using a SaaS system.
So if you had an, originally,
a SaaS web based application
which was multi-tenant,
same patterns do apply,
there is not much of a change,
it's just how you look
at it that is different.
So, option one is you can
have multiple instances
of the same agent deployed,
one for each tenant.
Again, complete isolation,
you get complete boundary separation.
The second option is you can
have an endpoint deployed.
So, when you deploy an agent to AgentCore,
you can have multiple versions
and each version can have
endpoints associated with them.
So, you can say that
endpoint A is for client A,
endpoint B is for client B,
and you can associate it with that way.
Again, you have some degree of separation,
you call it separately,
but behind the scenes there
is the same agent going on.
Or, you can just have a single endpoint
and do everything in the
code within your agent.
So, now you just have one
instance of it running.
But remember even when there
is one instance of it running,
every time you invoke an agent,
it's a completely
different isolated session
that AgentCore gives you.
So we, so a session when user A calls
an agent for tenant A,
and a user B calls an
agent for 10B, same agent,
we completely isolate
that session for you.
So there is no need to go
with option one or two.
You can just have a single
endpoint and handle it.
If you do decide to do one or two,
that is also a fair game.
It's just additional management
that you will have to go through.
So, that's the decision point.
Whether I want more separation
with little bit additional management
or I can handle it within my code.
Another thing to remember
about multi-tenancy is cost attribution.
So, that's where the hotel logging
that we were saying open
telemetry that comes into play.
We will, you will need to log those
for auditing purposes and cost allocation.
So, make sure that if you
have a multi-tenant system,
you'll log enough things
around it and use hotel,
and then you can use that anywhere.
Finally, we come to observability.
So, observability is slightly different.
I mean you need the standard observability
that you need for any system,
but agentic observability
is slightly different.
Here, you need to trace
every single component
what's going through it,
why did the agent make this decision,
how did it make that decision?
Is it calling this system, this agent
and then this agent and this tool,
all that traceability, right?
You need all of that
to understand to debug
and finally to audit it as well.
That's where observability comes in.
So, out of the box, as we said,
like CloudWatch dashboards are provided,
you can go and do session level tracing.
So, if you look at one of the dashboards
that we provide out of the box,
you can click into a session,
you can click into every single
component, how long it took,
what was the request,
what was the response,
all of that detail is available.
But if you already have a third
party observability system,
Langfuse, LangSmith, something different,
feel free to use that.
We have the hotel logs provided to you,
take that, feed it to
your existing system.
That's a fair game as well.
So, both those options are
fully compatible with AgentCore.
Finally, a futuristic agent,
an agent observing all the other agents,
and that's where you want
to eventually get to.
It'll come to our final solution.
So, this is the solution
that Epsilon has implemented.
What it did is all the patterns
that we have discussed,
they are talked about here.
So, for communication,
we standardized on Okta.
So, we are using Okta
for security authentication authorization,
communicating between the agents.
We are using Boto3 here.
So, every agent is talking
with each other using Boto3 APIs.
We are deploying some agents in an account
so that they can talk to
these native databases.
So, let's say for example Neptune
or any of these other
databases that we are there,
which are private in a particular VPC.
Same with the APIs on the right hand side,
if you see the PeopleCloud messaging APIs,
so those are the enterprise
APIs that are there.
And those APIs are protected through
or accessed via the gateway.
We standardized as I said on Okta.
So, MCP servers, gateway, agent
to agent, everything is Okta
for security purposes
and then we access the APIs through that.
Yeah.
So, if you want to take away
few things from the deep dive
of this portion, one thing is don't build
a single monolith agent but split
it into a micro agent, doing
a small amount of work, right?
What I've seen is while
you may have this kind
of architecture on a picture,
they build it into a
single agent in LangGraph,
using a workflow or something like that.
No, separate it out.
Each can be scalable on its own.
The second thing is security.
Day one, day zero, like, you need to have
that built in trust but verify,
that should be their
principle for security.
The third is the multi-tenancy.
Build it from day one.
So, make sure if you need multi-tenancy,
it's built into it right from the get go,
so that you don't have to
go back and refactor it.
Now, I'm going to hand over to Prashanth,
who's going to show you all
the magic of the AgentCore,
how these agents are implemented.
- [Prashanth] All right.
- [Jiten] Clicker,
- Clicker.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, thank you Jiten.
To go over AgentCore
architectural patterns
to address marketing
automation challenges.
Hello everyone, I'm Prashanth Athota,
SVP of Product Engineering
at Epsilon Data Management.
You guys hear me okay?
All right, thank you.
So, today I kind of go over,
first of all, who we are,
what we do and the type
of the opportunities
we identified to build agents
within our product and ecosystem.
And the type of the agents
we build using AgentCore
and Bedrock, and a small
demo of those agents at play.
Probably most interesting
part of the my whole deck.
And the benefits and the challenges
we faced while building those agents,
lessons learned, I would say.
Right?
So...
All right about Epsilon.
Epsilon Data Management
or Epsilon in short is a
subsidiary of Publicis Group.
World's leading advertising
and marketing company.
Epsilon is a data-driven
marketing company,
providing data technology
and services to help our clients
understand their customers
and engage them across various
communication channels.
At Epsilon we serve many industries
like QuickServe, finance,
retail, automotive
in a, there's like CPG,
travel and advertising,
so many and so forth.
All right.
So, what makes Epsilon
unique in this industry?
Customer identity.
We carry over 200 million
privacy protected IDs,
linking address, name and at
least a single transaction.
95% of them are verified
and a 100% are data mistake.
And the data, we host
national consumer database,
consists over 200 million plus consumers.
Self-reported over a
thousand plus attributes,
over $3 trillion spent transactions.
And our best in care
solutions like digital media,
retail media, network, clean rooms,
customer data platform,
loyalty and messaging.
Also industry leading support services.
So, at Epsilon we believe
in person-first marketing.
Our one view, like, using
our data and identity,
we provide a single comprehensive view
of the universe to potential buyers
for their marketers products.
And then with our one
vision we understand who
to engage, when to engage
and, you know, using their real-time,
like, you know, the spend
and then the one voice
delivering an experience
that relevant at personalized
for each individual at a point in time.
So these are the kind of,
you know, we look back
and say, "Okay, what are the improvements?
Where we can use our agents?"
So, some of the areas
is effective personalized messaging,
kind of providing the targeted
message at the right time
for the right individual.
By doing that the results are like,
you know, we get a higher
engagement for that message.
And then dynamic customer
journey orchestration
to provide user experience,
relevant to the user transaction,
which will in turn improve
the conversion rates.
Integrated systems for engagement,
so we would like to
bring the agents together
so we can integrate all
these products together,
so we have more, obviously,
less use resource usage
and more efficiently, and
operating those products.
And then the rapid
innovation and automation.
Building our GenAI platform,
helped us to build agents
at much faster speeds
and to reduce, you know,
improve the time to market.
All right, so driving the performance
across the owned channels.
Most of the brands they would like
to know their customers
and to create effective
segments are the audience.
To do that, we build the agents.
One is like our 360 degree customer view
and audience.ai.
Audience.ai is more like,
instead of understanding their databases,
complex relationships,
complex SQL statements,
they can literally write a plain text
and get their segments done,
with the plain English.
And then defining the
campaigns across the channels.
So type of the like agents we build,
like, a brief agent campaign,
brief agent, branding
agent, creation agent
and campaign agent.
And AI assisted on demand and scheduling.
So, they're all coming
together, like, multiple agents
to build those campaigns.
And then once the campaign is generated,
once the campaign is executed,
we have agents kind of
measuring the performance
and readjusting the optimizing
the strategy of those campaigns.
So, whether it is campaign analytics,
agents consuming the insights, et cetera.
So, here is the kind of a timelines,
like, our journey when
we started back in 2024.
In Q2 we introduced the GenAI,
which is more for the audience creation,
where this platform can build audience
or segments using the plain English text
to SQL conversion.
Then we kind of in Q3
implemented Subject Line,
Image tagging on the Bedrock,
you know, some of those agents.
Beginning of this year we have
the first content creation,
our HTML agent and then the Q3,
we kind of introduced AI into our SDLC,
which definitely improved
our productivity,
getting almost like 20 plus
agents in a short time period.
And creating the content
monitoring, et cetera,
on our platforms.
And at present we have seven
plus teams working alongside
of AWS, building our agentic platform.
And that said, I believe we're
gonna go for a small demo
of all these agents coming
together, playing along.
Yes.
- [Announcer] Every minute
brands send tens of thousands
of emails and the vast...
- Sorry.
- [Announcer] Every minute
brands send tens of thousands
of emails and the vast
majority land in blind inboxes.
With Epsilon that ends.
Engage with customers on a
deeper level across all devices.
Let me show you how Epsilon
agents build campaigns.
Every strong brand starts
with a clear message.
Inside Epsilon messaging,
that message begins with a campaign brief,
built on decades of Epsilon's
identity intelligence
and marketing precision.
A campaign doesn't start with chaos,
it starts with structure.
Epsilon messaging instantly
organizes intent into a clean,
dependable workflow.
Choosing email here
isn't selecting a format,
it's activating one of
the most trusted channels
in modern marketing.
With a few details the
platform aligns data, context
and audience signals behind the scenes.
Shaping a foundation the brand
can build on confidently.
The editor opens not as a blank canvas
but as a guided space
where the brand's voice
naturally finds clarity
and direction.
Templates remove the
burden of design guessing.
Branding is applied with precision.
So, every message aligns
with the brand's identity,
instantly recognizable, always consistent.
Once the template is in place,
the brand stands on solid ground,
the styling is locked, the look is unified
and the message can now
focus purely on meaning.
A generic campaign fades fast,
but when Epsilon's AI
agents shape the audience,
timing and message, your
campaign hits with precision
and drives real action.
When the message fits the moment,
the channel becomes effortless
with Epsilon messaging.
Edits that once required, long back
and forth cycles become frictionless.
Phrasing flow and rhythm,
adjust with a level of precision
that keeps the message sharp.
Suggestions add another
layer, subtle, thoughtful,
grounded in brand tone and clarity.
The small refinements that
elevate communication.
Personalization becomes identity driven.
No long segmentation
work, no manual filtering.
Relevance at scale,
supported by the industry's
most trusted data.
Dynamic elements bring
the message to life.
Effortlessly adding motion, interaction
and depth without additional
creative complexity.
Tone controls bring discipline,
professional when needed,
optimistic when desired,
a brand's voice clearly expressed
the way it was intended.
Readability and visual
refinements enhance comprehension.
Clean spacing, balance, design
and structured hierarchy.
Guide the reader through
the message effortlessly.
With one click, the message
sharpens into its final form.
Campaigns miss when they lack relevance.
Epsilon's AI agents
build relevance at scale
so your message lands and
your customer responds.
A full review confirms
the message is aligned,
structured and ready.
Device previews show consistency
across screens and environments.
Timing decisions, shape performance.
Epsilon messaging aligns delivery
with patterns proven through
identity intelligence
and decades of engagement data.
And with that the message moves
from creation to execution.
Built with precision using AI agents,
strengthened by identity,
delivered through Epsilon messaging.
The platform, the world's
strongest brand's trust
to communicate with
clarity, scale, and purpose.
- Okay, all right.
So, now, I'm gonna go over like the type
of the benefits we observed
by building all these agents
across our product suite.
Agent prototyping.
By using the AgentCore,
definitely we see like reduced
the prototyping time, number of,
you know, days it took,
from weeks to days actually.
And then campaign set up time it's,
we observed 30% improvements.
But, again, as the adoption goes up
across campaign managers and analysts,
I'm sure that we are gonna see more.
Personalization capacity increased by 20%.
Campaign creation times.
Obviously we saved many number of hours,
but, again, this is all we just starting
with multiple agents.
As we build more and more
agents across other areas,
we're definitely going to
see a lot more improvements
or savings I guess.
So, the lessons learned,
you know, it's kind of,
we used to spend a lot
of time, manually, creating workflows
versus switch our focus
now more, like, automation
and outcome-based journeys.
And we also have the teams
changing their mindset,
what to think about more of outcome
than what to do and how to do things.
So, even in any use cases,
like, instead of worrying
about what models out there
or what they're coming up with,
where you should more focus
on, like, what are the type
of problems we're trying to solve
or the outcomes we are looking for.
And then look for the
models that more suited
for your needs rather than
going after model by model.
And rapid prototyping.
Definitely, you know, using
some platforms like AgentCore,
using like their plug-and-play
abstraction layer,
planner compliance and recommendations,
it'll help you to build, experiment
and deploy the agents at speed.
And using something like Amazon Queue,
integrating with your SDLC.
Improved us, like, you
know, especially AI-DLC
and also AI pipelines, integrating them,
definitely helped us to
speed up our iterations
and fail fast.
And then what's next?
Autonomous everywhere.
We would like to expand our agents,
use of agents from marketing over
to other areas like auto,
data and other platforms.
Loyalty and other areas.
And building self-healing,
self-monitoring type of agents.
Also integrating the AI-DLC
pipelines with the operations
so we can have autonomous agents,
working for maintaining the
platform, and stability,
and secure, safe security
and compliance, et cetera.
And a unified intelligence layer
by using the agent gateway,
bringing all the products together.
So we have MCPs and the
tools are all coming,
working together and the data
is shared across the products
using the same agents,
exposed to same agents.
And commercializing and acceleration.
We'd like to take these
architectural patterns
and ex, you know, and also build agents
that can be used by our clients
or let the clients build
their agents using our data,
using our APIs and et cetera.
And also publish some of these agents
in the marketplace.
So, you know, we can kind
of monetize based on those.
All right, that said.
Sandeep, you know, complete.
- All right, am I still audible?
You like me?
Yes?
Good.
All right, so here are some of the res,
learning resources that, I think,
will be really helpful for you.
These are some of the things
that I refer to every day.
There are great examples in
sample code on GitHub as well.
And there are free learning
courses on Skill Builder,
AWS Skill Builder.
So, please take advantage of these
and have as much as hands-on
practice as possible
so that you can build
those great AI agents
and deploy on top of
Bedrock AgentCore services.
And if you love us, you can
clap at the end of the session,
but first remember that you
have to fill the survey,
especially look at my face, I'm very,
you know, innocent, I'm a nice person.
Please do fill the session
survey and give us good ratings.
Okay?
Thank you so much guys.
Take care.
(crowd clapping)